president biden telling the white house
to batten down the hatches because it is
about to get rough the president getting
rocked by more brutal poll numbers as
crises pile up biden instructing ace to
get into campaign mode and find ways to
avoid making the midterms about his job
performance but time could be running
out his approval rating is still in a
nosedive hitting a new low of just 39
percent and house democrats are also
sounding the alarm on staggering
inflation as fears of midterm election
losses loom even some in the media
chiming in on the serious trouble
democrats face in november
that voters views about the economy
begin to harden in an election year
around may that theory holds democrats
are in some serious trouble right now
because in our new nbc news poll just 16
say the country's headed in the right
direction while a whopping 75 percent
say we're on the wrong track in fact
that wrong track number has been 70 plus
for seven months which in the past has
signaled big losses for the governing
party biden also getting a reality check
from amazon founder jeff bezos the
billionaire scolding biden for tying
corporate tax rates to soaring inflation
and tweeting the administration tried
hard to inject even more stimulus into
an already overheated inflationary
economy and only mansions save them from
themselves inflation is a regressive tax
that hurt that most hurts the least
affluent misdirection doesn't help the
country and today peter ducey asked the
new press secretary karine jean-pierre
about that very issue let's take a look
how does raising taxes on corporations
lower the cost of gas the cost of a used
car the cost of food for everyday
americans so look i think we encourage
those who have done very well right
especially those who care about climate
change
to support a fair attack tax code that
doesn't change that doesn't charge
manufacturers workers cops builders a
higher percentage of their earnings that
the most fortunate people in our nation
and not let this this that stand in the
way of reducing energy costs and
fighting this existential problem
jesse waters i don't know if that really
answered the question not a great first
day that's the only part of the day i
saw but that wasn't very difficult but
first days are not okay hopefully she
gets better than that because reading
everyone can read okay um
this nbc news poll was really important
because it's nbc this is like the inside
the beltway
pristine peacock pole everybody puts it
up on sunday morning chuck todd meet the
press so that is very scary it's at 39
and the wrong way right way it's almost
75 in the wrong direction another poll
had 80 percent in the wrong direction
hasn't been that bad since right after
january 6 in the impeachment so these
are pretty startling numbers biden says
he's instructing aids to get tough for
the midterms no he's not the aides are
instructing biden to get tough he's the
puppet and everybody knows that why is
that he came into office with all this
great political capital remember he was
supposed to be the healer but now that
people feel like it's been false
advertising right he hasn't healed
anything everything has gotten worse
he's like the doctor you go in you tell
him your leg hurts he said rub some
cream on it and your leg falls off it's
gotten worse at least trump you knew
what you were getting when you put him
in office you were getting a feisty
rabble rouser biden was supposed to make
everything feel better and everything's
gotten worse feels like third world
vibes
are you
high crime high inflation
you can't get stuff there's shortages
empty shelves this is not the america
people love and respect now if you go in
and you blow up the border and then
divide the country with max vax mandates
and then screw up afghanistan everyone's
going to be like whoa whoa what is going
on but then when you add to that is lack
of vision he didn't see two coveted
waves coming and he didn't see inflation
coming you're seeing a guy that's just
hapless as a leader and you can either
be a
poor leader and a good politician or a
poor politician and a good leader biden
is bad at both and the american people
now realize that i'm wondering about
this idea that biden is now telling his
staff to get into campaign mode because
i remember it was early on when the
georgia voting law was passed remember
he called republicans bull connor i mean
i don't know if the campaigning ever
really stopped on either side i would
like them to be in campaign mode all the
time right i wish they worked as hard
on the problems that we face
that they work when they when they fear
that they're going to lose power like
generally we don't have people in
america don't have campaign modes that's
called work right you know it's like you
know if
if our job was to care about crime and
the police and inflation in the border
these are things that you would care
about year round as opposed to six
months prior to a midterm and i think
that most political leaders would be
nice to see what happened if they were
forced to campaign year round right
because that's what we when we have a
job right we just don't get a job and
then who we're in you have to prove
yourself every day real jobs whether
it's sales or customer service you have
job reviews you have bosses you have
deadlines but once politicians win an
election it's like they stop working
they go oh well i'm in and then they
unroll their sleeves and i think that's
why trump was so unusual because and why
he was so hated because he was in work
mode his he was in campaign mode all the
time and people were like
he's exhausting but the dems suffer from
a weird flaw they're always political so
the problems don't exist until they
become political and then they're
ill-equipped to fix them because they're
not used to fixing problems you're only
causing them right and what do you think
about when americans say that 75 of
american people according to the nbc
polls say that they think the country's
going in the wrong direction i mean
that's actually some pretty good
bipartisanship right there 75
that's a great point dana i never
thought of it like that well look you
know
what do you have when you have a
president a commander-in-chief
who can't see things when they're right
before his very eyes i mean
jesse you said he didn't see covert
coming he didn't see inflation coming
donald trump told us inflation was
coming donald trump trump told us the
gas prices were going up and then now
six months prior to a midterm the guy
decides well gee we better get in
campaign mode no the truth is you don't
know how to how to do anything get into
it or get out of it so what do they do
they have nothing to talk about in terms
of what they've accomplished so they
pick on the republicans and so they say
you know what the republicans are
terrible and they think that we're
stupid that if they pull the wool over
our eyes we'll say yeah those
republicans they were really terrible i
only paid two dollars a gallon for gas
inflation was 2
now it's 8.3 or 5
you know i mean they just think that
we're stupid enough to buy what they're
selling and we're beyond that we're
absolutely beyond it right now american
families are are anguishing and and they
are they are hurting they're hurting for
baby formula he knew that was coming he
did nothing about it his health and
human services becerra said we knew this
last year and then afghanistan he knew
we had to get out of afghanistan it was
the worst get out of the country that
we've ever seen in fact he should have
taken the weapons that he left there and
given them to the ukrainians we'd be
better off great idea so geraldo one of
the things that they have been doing in
the white house is having to deal with
the far left
so in some ways they've also been
campaigning internally for a long time
because they know that joe manchin and
kirsten cinema are basically helping
protect them from
bad votes but yet they still continue to
try to drive that messaging to the left
in order to placate that base if they
drive title 42 to be abolished a week
from today
they will have helped destroy the biden
presidency i think it would be a
self-inflicted injury of a monumental
dimension
and the reverberations might result in a
route in november and uh more
importantly in 2024.
i think that with
inflation with immigration
with crime the democrats are doomed
except for one thing
this leak in the supreme court of the
abortion decision has changed the
political calculus in this country and i
think that we don't address it we don't
deal with it in a straightforward way
because it will i see it already in
little in little cleveland
over the weekend thousands turned out as
they did in hundreds of other places
around the country
i think what the supreme court has done
is ignite the suburbs and they could
change the entire dynamic of the
election
despite
inflation and immigration and crime and
uh ukraine and so forth i think it is so
emotionally fraught
that it has the it has the capacity of
changing the conversation right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else